that's who are credible to understand  I'm serious you think I don't bother  when I decided that this war is wrong  because I'm single yeah I'll hold  oh look it meeting in there let's keep  your head now  [Music]  so I told you about my brother yet  something happened I don't know exactly  what she's been arrested being held at  Rikers Island oh my god that's all just  got to get him out of there before  something bad happens you get killed in  this  Oh  another 10 grant you get another 10  grand  you bow get out  [Music]  I pick something very important is  happening and distinctly connected to my  purpose every day I think about on  twisting untangling these streams I'm in  to lead a Pure Life look ahead a clear  sky ain't gonna get there but it's a  nice dream  since I stream  [Music]  you